hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you
lately we've been talking a lot about on
this show we're going to talk about it
tonight the freedom in the arts
you know
you've written some
episodes of one i can think of off the
top of my head of the office which they
don't show now
i see jamie foxx's new movie
was shelved i guess he made it a few
years ago but they're not going to ever
show it
um they make less comedies
i mean you found a way to make a comedy
about something
but i'm sure you have to be very careful
about a lot of different things they're
making less because it's not worth it
to even try
where are you on that i think that the
there's a difference between the
gatekeepers and the audience and i think
you probably see this firsthand as a
stand-up the audiences i think are
pretty down
for
everything they're pretty smart people
and um
and and can be
can be trusted can be trusted a lot more
than the gatekeepers sometimes worry i
think the gatekeepers are worried about
the chatter in their own spheres but i
think audiences can be can be trusted to
be pretty smart but it's not it's not in
the hands of the audience that's what
i'm saying
so i'm saying i think the problem i
don't think the problem is that
audiences are too sensitive i think the
problem is that people are worried that
other people are too sensitive right